[MUSIC]
MARGARET MARTONOSI:
Hi, my name is
Margaret Martonosi. I've been
on the Princeton faculty
for 23 years.
I'm a computer scientist,
and I work in CITP as well.
And I'm here as a
panelist on the panel
on internet of things.
First of all, the relevance
of the conference itself,
I think it's really struck
a nerve with a lot of people
to examine what democracy means
in an era where information
flows freely in many
ways, and what's
technology's role in that.
And I think it's particularly
important for technologists
to be a part of that discussion.
We often, as
computer scientists,
we develop technology, and then
sort of throw it over the fence
for it to be used
in different ways.
It's important for us to
be in the conversation
about how it gets used
and its implications.
ASA CRAIG: Hi, my
name is Asa Craig.
I'm a graduate student
in the Woodrow Wilson
School, a second-year
MPA student, studying
domestic public policy.
And I'm here in Berlin,
one, because I just
thought the topic was very
interesting, and really
important in terms of what do we
know about what the internet is
going to do for our rights and
our liberties moving forward.
I just want to be a
part of the conversation.
And I'm here helping
out and volunteering.
So I think the one
interesting thing with my role
is that I get to see that
this is really a show.
We have speakers from
all over the world that
are coming to chat from
all different walks of life
in different organizations,
different countries,
different languages.
And we have to just make sure
that people are ready to go,
get on stage when they're
supposed to be there,
and that when we
start and we end
at the right and
appropriate time.
And so I'm the person that's
looking at the schedule,
and saying we have
five minutes left.
This should be
the last question.
So I'm just looking
at the clock,
and saying OK, let me see if
I can get their attention,
and to let them know that
it's time to wrap up.
CLAUDIA SCHMIDT-MEMMLER: My
name is Claudia Schmidt-Memmler,
and I work at the international
strategy office at Humboldt
University, here in Berlin.
And we are an international
strategic partner of Princeton
University, and I am
responsible for the connection
to Princeton, and the connection
between Humboldt and Princeton.
And that's why I'm here.
It was really
interesting, already,
in the time leading
up to the conference,
when I started thinking
about these issues
around digitalization,
and liberty, and politics.
It popped up everywhere.
In German media, my
focus was so on it.
And I realized there's a
lot of debate going on,
and it's really a
topic that is spot on,
and so current in Germany,
as well in the U.S., I'm sure.
ASA CRAIG: It's just
interesting to get
to really connect not only with
what is happening on stage,
but to think about
what is the process
of the whole for throwing
this type of a conference.
MARGARET MARTONOSI:
As a Princeton person,
we have a notion of
an orange bubble.
We sometimes talk about
where we stay on campus
and we think great
thoughts, but it's
important to have
impact out in the world.
I think Princetonians already
have tremendous impact
out in the world in
many different ways.
So it's not like
this is particularly
new in that respect.
But it's important to highlight
when we're trying to do that,
and to make it as
visible as possible,
and to bring those conversations
to as many different regions
of the world as possible.
And so in that
respect, I think this
is another great
example of things
we're doing in that line.